former New York City Mayor Michael
Bloomberg says EPA Administrator Scott
Pruett is failing to do the job he was
hired for the billionaire businessman
criticized Pruitt's pro-business
approach in an interview Margaret
Brennan for Sunday's Face the Nation his
policies are not good for the world that
to debunk science and walk away from it
is just ridiculous for saying he's not
doing the job that he should be doing I
don't think there's any question about
that he was hired his job is to protect
the environment and he has walked away a
hundred percent from that and the mayor
is clear you can see Margaret's full
interview with Michael Bloomberg Sunday
on Face the Nation where the former
mayor will also make a big announcement
related to climate change Margaret also
talks with senators Tom cotton and
Dianne Feinstein plus our own John
Dickerson that's Face the Nation Sunday
here on CBS John Dickerson Wow going
back to the first you can go home again
don't forget to come back you mean come
back home here come back home here
that's what I mean come back to the
table on Monday